what would the world look like if
everybody was contained you know a lot
of people have heard about dopamine it's
about more it's about the future you
know most people who can to comprehend
what you just said it's easy to go out
buy a cell phone it's easy to go out and
buy a new car it's not gonna get you
happiness and that's when your
experience is dealing with people that
are on drugs they slam it with a
chemical blast I need to get more clicks
I need to get more likes this could
cause us to not have enough babies well
how about the end of the human race so I
think it's time to smoke weed so if you
want to light it up a little too deep
right now so what is the biggest threat
with porn when virtual reality and
augmented reality comes you start out
with tame stuff and little by little you
go up to more and more extreme acts what
is the divorce rate right now in America
50 percent how many people have an
extramarital affair and two years later
say best thing I ever did now you don't
do that you don't hear that on average
liberals do have on higher IQ than
conservatives and there's a hand
sanitizer nearby the presence of the
hand sanitizer made the more
conservative you know the signs that
said employees must wash their hands
those are advertisers for the
Republicans are you kidding me are you
trying to tell everybody that's watching
just to set the phone aside and have sex
with somebody rights exactly and that's
what you're saying yes that's what I
think and if anything is gonna save us
that's what's gonna save us
did you ever think you would make it I
feel like it takes sweet victory I know
this slice meant for me yeah why would
you bet on Goliath well we got plenty
value Kaman given values contagious this
world of entrepreneurs we can't no value
the haters honey run homie look what I
become I'm the one
[Music]
so today I have a special guest with me
dr. Daniel Z Lieberman who is an author
a professor and a psychiatrist and today
we are going to talk about his latest
book called a molecule of more how a
single chemical in your brain drives
love sex and creativity and will
determine the fate of the human race dr.
Daniel Lieberman thank you for coming
out that's a pretty strong statement
right there to say determine the fate of
human race what do you think about that
well you know it is pretty strong and it
gets a lot of attention yeah but we
didn't write that title until we
finished writing the book and the second
last chapter in the book is all about
the ways this chemical dopamine could
bring the world to an end and you know
we hearing about it all the time I know
I think the first semi was used what was
in 1957 some timeline I read about some
lady Karen I don't know if it's maybe
you can tell us about a word of war
dopamine came about yeah so originally
we thought that this chemical was simply
a precursor molecule to make a different
chemical in the brain called
norepinephrine okay
that's closely related to adrenaline the
fight-or-flight molecule so it was just
thought that it was this intermediate
step not important then it turned out
that it was a neurotransmitter in its
own right a neurotransmitter being a
chemical the brain uses to process
information since then we found out it's
probably one of the single most
important neurotransmitters in the brain
responsible for an unbelievably broad
variety of behaviors in human beings
have we already figured out enough of
this or is there more to learn about
this dopamine you understand what I'm
saying right like we are we at a place
where our data is clear enough where we
can trust the data and the studies that
are coming out or always fill yours
behind it there's there's always more to
learn
yeah and psychiatry the study of the
brain I think you'd be considered the
youngest of the medical scientists
simply because the brain is so complex
that said if you google the different
molecules Google Scholar which looks at
the medical journals the most
articles you're gonna find the most hits
are gonna be dopamine that's the one
scientists are most interested in so we
don't know everything there is to know
but we know a lot and a lot of the
studies the most important studies have
been replicated so we can have a fair
amount of time so I'm looking forward to
getting more educated on this dopamine
thing that we're talking about here and
it's not a drug but it plays as a form
of it but yeah here's the thing before
we get into it what what made you want
to say I want to study brains I mean at
what point did you decide I want to be a
psychiatrist how did that happen
well when I was in college I studied
philosophy I went to a special College
called st. John's College what's special
about it
is there are no textbooks there are no
lectures and there are no tests what you
do is you read original sources the
great books of Western civilization and
you get together in small groups and
discuss them and write about them so I
came out of there thinking all right
it's all about the human mind that
that's where everything that's beautiful
comes from so everything that's ugly
comes from as well so everything that's
important comes from but I know what I
wanted to do so I I went to Japan
because I had no job and friend mine was
Japanese he said I get a job over there
teaching English and while I was there I
ran across the writings of psychologist
Carl Jung and reading him I decided
that's what I want to do I want to spend
my career studying the brain
what What did he say that inspired you
was there any specific thing that stuck
it was it was the way he showed that the
human brain is a combination of two
things one is volition that's the
choices that we make the other is the
biological substrate that's the material
we've got to work with and I think that
that second part we neglect you know
it's easy to say well I can't control my
body especially as you get older Patrik
yeah true absolutely offer to get up in
the morning so it's tougher to get a lot
of things to get up you know in the
morning a bit older but yeah it is so
but we think about our mind the thing
between our ears is we have total
control over I want to think about a
giraffe I want to think about a cup of
coffee I can think about anything I want
and that's absolutely not
true the biological substrate of our
brain including the neurotransmitters
like dopamine in our brain they
determined so much of our experience and
a lot of people don't realize just how
much that is is there any linkage
between why you wanted to study this or
with anybody in your family upbringing
what you're like this reminds me of the
experience I had with my dad or my
mother or my sister or my uncle or
somebody where you said I want to go
deeper because you know sometimes when
it comes to health a lot of my friends
who are doctors or they go into this
mode there is somebody in their lives
that inspired them to go even deeper was
there any of that for you or not at all
there really was it I came from a family
of lawyers my father was a lawyer my
grandfather was a lawyer my uncle was a
lawyer and I was pretty sure I was going
to be a lawyer and so one one year one
summer I worked in my father's law firm
and I'd never been more bored in my life
so you know you were gonna do it yeah
after bad yeah so you go from lawyers to
want it to be a study philosophy well
you know I thought that I was gonna be
an engineer because I loved science got
it and then you know when you're in high
school colleges send you this PR stuff
mm-hmm so st. John's College their PR
stuff is a list of the books you read
Plato Aristotle the Iliad Thomas Aquinas
Saint Agustin Newton Einstein I looked
at this list and I said I got to read
these books I I don't think I can be an
educated person without reading these
books what a great way to market by the
way yeah what a great I mean if you if
you know cuz somebody's gonna read this
I don't care to know about any of these
guys but someone's gonna read and say I
want to know everything about these guys
so it's gonna attract the people that
you want were you always a reader and
have an interest in philosophy I was
always a read okay I'm not necessarily
interested in philosophy but I was the
kid who wanted to stay inside and read
what other people were all playing
football
that was so we like their four point
something GPA you did great in school
the whole nine that kind of icky not
quite that good yeah I read a lot yeah
you read a yeah that's cool my kid is a
this summer he read 70 books very broad
kid yeah he's a he's seven years old so
he's all about reading and every time I
start reading something he just wants to
come next to me it's one of the things I
wanted to pass to these kids because I
don't to jump by maybe six five
don'tjump I I don't play good basketball
or baseball if you ever see me throw a
first pitch I throw first pitch at a
game a month ago and was the most
embarrassing first pitch you'll ever see
in your life is so the only that can
pass on to these guys is if you get
reading gone because that's what change
your dad's life but okay so your dad's a
lawyer
your grandfather's are like the same
grandfather they told me that was in
Germany or the other side other side oh
yeah about that grandfather if you can
talk about him because he's got an
interesting story he's got a my father
and my father's family were born in
Germany and they were Jews and they had
a big family there they'd come from
Poland and my grandfather was a furrier
he made fur coats and that sort of thing
and he moved to Berlin because they
needed they need people in that industry
there
Nazis came to power and people start
saying hey you need to get out he didn't
want to get out he had his life there he
had a store there his business there he
said look I was invited here no one's
gonna do anything to me I'm working hard
I'm a good citizen of course he was
wrong and he waited and waited and
waited
he had a an apprentice that he was
teaching the business young young German
man member of the Nazi youth get out of
here one day he comes he said you got to
get out tomorrow it's going down
you're gonna take you on a whole family
away oh now they left that night little
suitcase left everything behind made it
out one step ahead the Nazis came the
United States you ever seen a movie
pianist
I haven't seen that if you ever seen
it's a really really good movie it's the
whole story is this guy that played very
good piano and the Nazi soldiers took a
liking in him when he would play and
they kind of helped him save and he up
some guys but so very similar store when
you hear these stories it's a very
admirable to have their kid do something
like that knowing he's part of the youth
Nazi just Telstra even then there was
some heart and these kids to say I want
to save this guy's life that's the
beautiful part of the story yeah
so what did your grandpa end up doing
when he came up here he he started you
open foyer in Buffalo New York that's
wrong successful yes I would say
successful you know he didn't get he
didn't have a chain of them
we had one and
good middle-class life sent my father to
law school sent my uncle to medical
school good for me you kidding me that's
great us did that's exactly okay so
you're raising this family and by the
way mother side what did your mom your
mother was odd they had been in Buffalo
for a number of generations yeah they
came interesting story on that side of
the family if I can tell it sure my
great-grandfather was in the Russian
army
and they were they were involved in some
kind of retreat I don't even know what
war it is but his boots fell apart and
he couldn't walk all these miles so they
had to leave him hidden in some town
rest of his company they make it in this
town they're going to they I'll get on a
train train is bombed everybody is
killed his family thought that he had
been killed too and I don't know months
years later he shows obviously I missed
the train my boots wore out wow I feel
pretty I got luck so so they meet him
buffalo yeah are you Bills fan or no you
know I I've been in the past I'm not
writing I've suffered enough
okay yeah I used to be a die-hard Bills
fan when I came to the stage you did
House a Thurman Thomas BB Brice pop you
know Bruce I'm in Flutie all of those
guys that was a die-hard Bills fan but
that's a whole different they're doing
actual pretty okay right now they are
for once so so you go from there you go
to st. John you study all these
philosophers which one of the
philosophers stuck out to you not in
Japan I'm talking about here all these
people you're studying who stuck out you
as the one that had the biggest positive
influence and was there anybody who said
this guy's off mm-hmm yeah so I think
the one that had the biggest positive
influence was Plato you know he wrote
about Socrates
and he wrote about how you really need
to carefully test the things you believe
with reason because the things that we
intuitively think are true stuff to do
for a lot of people they're not always
true that's right and you know intuition
is effortless and that's not to say it's
valueless omission is effortless it just
comes to us it's a gut feeling and it
can be enormous ly valuable and it's
often right but we gotta test it and it
takes effort
to test it with reason and a lot of
times we skipped that step but he made
the point that that's very very
important and some interesting things
come out of it I mean he asked the most
fundamental questions what is justice
what is the good and got some very
interesting interesting things that came
out of it
so that's Plato how about the one that
was the most wackiest guy cuz you know
philosophers they think they have a very
interesting they can be pretty well yes
yeah boy
III wasn't a big fan of the
existentialist you know the
existentialist the way I interpreted
them and I'm certainly on extra-nice
angel' ISM but they basically say
there's no help out there you're on your
own there's no God
there's there's there's no meaning you
have to create all the meaning yourself
you live in a cold meaningless universe
deal with it you can't buy them I don't
buy that
how about stoicism what would you do you
know or elias marcus aurelius right
nothing is good or bad it's only how you
perceive yeah yes so yeah I think it's a
beautiful philosophy I think though it
may be a little bit over optimistic in
terms of the strength that human beings
have these guys were amazing that that
they could do that they could live their
life that way I think it's pretty tough
for the ordinary person though to live
that way and limited they did this at a
tough time today wouldn't it be easier
to live that today versus then maybe
maybe you know things got a lot better
for us from a material sense yeah I'm
not sure things have gotten any better
from an emotional sense though let's
talk about that yeah that's more I mean
it's easy to go out and buy a cell phone
it's easy to go out and buy a new car
it's not gonna get you happiness some of
the things we talked about in the book
that there's a difference between
wanting something and liking it once you
get it there's a difference between your
brain driving you to collect resources
that are going to be useful from a
survival evolutionary point of view
those roots mean that and living a happy
fulfilling satisfying life of content
and I'm not sure all of the prosperity
and technology we have helps us all that
much with the latter you don't think so
so let me ask you this so you know
scriptures different religions they all
talk about contentment you know finding
ways to get to that point what would the
world look like if everybody was content
it wouldn't yeah because I like I think
about that right you sit on us okay
let's just say you and I sit down and we
agree on everything what a boring dinner
yeah we go to dinner we're sitting out
our luck okay yeah I agree
how about this cool how about this okay
all right so uh you know you wanna go
there's gotta be a little bit of that I
feel so that's right you gotta have the
spark right gotta have the spark of
conflict I I think so because you know
when a lot of people come and tell me
the like how do you view world peace
tell me what you think about world peace
when somebody says we gotta have world
peace how do you process that as a
psychiatrist how do you process that
it's a beautiful idea it's probably
realist unrealistic it's unreal it's not
the way the human brain evolved we
evolved to fight because we we we grew
up I mean we evolved in very difficult
circumstances do you think that's okay I
I don't think that's the right way to
look at I don't think it's a value
judgment I think it's a fact that's
those that's the way our DNA is in our
body and we can't do anything so you're
making it like a law of gravity it's
it's just gonna be that way there's
nothing we can do about it that's it
yeah I kind of agree with you there but
sometimes you got a lot of people that
want to force change and when you try to
force change you create enemies i I
don't know if you ever read the book by
dr. Hawkins power versus force I don't
know if you've ever read our verses or
that it was on one of Oprah's top 10
list 20 years ago or something like that
and I read this book 17 years ago and he
says that everybody has certain levels
that you go through from the lowest
level to the highest level of
consciousness enlightenment being at
highest than its peace joy love and then
one of the highest levels he has below
love is reason okay learning kind of
reason yeah then below reason is I think
it's willingness acceptance you know a
neutrality meaning I can sit down with
you and you can have a view and he can
have a view and I can get along with
both of you guys because I can be
neutral and kind of be able to have the
same relationship with both and then the
first lowest level of consciousness he
says that it's in a good areas courage
you have the courage to face your fears
and then below it at the lowest I think
it's shame apathy grief pride anger you
know desire like these are like sex
these are not desire to do something big
with your life and he breaks these
levels down very very interesting when
you think about it so for me it's when
you said a world peace can it exists you
know I don't think it's something that
is a good thing or bad thing it's a fact
that's something that's gonna happen how
do you teach for all of us to long how
to reason better how do we do that how
do we get a society to be opening open
to reasoning more with each other how do
we get to that kind of a place I think
the first step is to identify the
challenges because an important question
is well why don't we reason all the time
right
why aren't we rational creatures because
a lot of times we behave irrationally
we're hurting ourselves more than anyone
else so you know we've got we've got
these biological drives that are
manifested in the organization of our
brain anatomy and that's the same with
other animals we've got a lot in common
with other animals we share 50% of our
genes with bananas and 99% of our genes
with chimpanzees so 50% of my genes are
tied to bananas they're the exact same
genes as bananas have get out of here
50% really yeah 99% same chimp two
chimpanzees have maybe that's why that
arts so 420 go with that bananas percent
with bananas that's right so than 99%
which in pansy
that's right so 1% that's 1% is what
makes us human and in that little tiny
piece that makes us human we got reason
and reason completely changed the story
because in some ways reason has allowed
us not completely but to partially sever
our selves from our biological roots we
have to eat we have to get calories
we're at the mercy of the physical laws
but our brains can rise above it and
look at abstract laws and that ability
to reason is what has allowed us to
become the dominant race on this earth
through technology through inventions
through the ability to in some ways act
against our biological nature when
that's in our best interest but we have
to remember it's hard because reason is
powerful and what it's able to do but it
is weak in terms of its motive force
inside of our brain meaning our
instincts are much more powerful so if I
instinctively want something maybe it's
food maybe it's sex but my reason tells
me hey maybe that's not the right thing
for you to do it's gonna be tough for
reason to win that battle instinct was
that about instinct says a lot is a lot
stronger
so instinct wins over reason does it
have anything to do with pleasure and
pain or not at all I think it does I
think it does you know one of the things
I do is treat people with drug addiction
and in that case you really see the
battle between reason and instinct in
drug addiction instinct in a way has
been twisted to want nothing more than
to use drugs that's destroying a
person's life so it's a little bit
different than ordinary instinct but
it's so powerful people will give up
their jobs their families their health
their homes they'll give up everything
to feed their brain with this toxic
substance and their reason knows that
this is the wrong thing to do but it's
powerless and so what they try to do is
use willpower they say all right I know
what the right thing to do is
I will simply will it to be thus doesn't
work it doesn't work will powers like a
muscle in that it fatigues very easily
I'll give you example of that if you're
interested in sure yeah
so they did this study called the
chocolates and radishes study they
brought people in a room and on the
table was freshly baked chocolate chip
cookie and a bowl of radishes and half
the people they said hey go ahead and
eat the cookies the other half they said
you can only eat the radishes afterwards
they had them work on a problem that was
impossible and telma was impossible and
they timed how long they worked at it
what do you think worked at it longer
chocolate yeah because the radish people
had already used up all their willpower
not eating the cookies in out of here
yeah so willpower is we interesting so
we teach them it's better to be smart
than strong if you're going to a party
where alcohol is going to be served and
you're an alcoholic and you can't drink
don't rely on willpower use strategy
bring a sober body who can look after
you and make sure you're not gonna drink
figure out some way to outsmart instinct
rather than trying to take it head-on
with willpower can you can you work on
it enough where you're eventually strong
on your own is that a permanent strategy
it it's a permanent strategy you can
strengthen your willpower that's what
the Stoics did the Stoics were like
willpower superheroes but it's hard to
do and hard to do why because why just
because of the nature of the willpower
circuits
they're just not that strong so so is it
a transferable thing to somebody else or
some people are wired to have a stronger
willpower than somebody else I think
they're wired well you you believe I
think it's just like muscles you know I
can build up muscles but I'm never gonna
be like a body boom right so a big part
of its genetic and then some of it is
exercising whether you're exercising
your will or your muscles you can build
it up a little bit I just don't think
it's a good strategy to rely on it and
that's been your experiences dealing
with people that are on drugs absolutely
yeah so what role does dopamine played
there
so you know a lot of people have heard
about dopamine as the pleasure molecule
and that's one thing it does dopamine
was originally made to make us desire
things that will benefit us
evolutionarily and reward us when we do
it so eat when you're hungry drink when
you're thirsty Reproduction winning
competitions these are natural things
the reason why drugs are so dangerous is
because they short-circuit these
survival pathways they hijack the
dopamine system and instead of gently
stimulating it like winning a
competition would do or eating a nice
meal they slam it with a chemical blast
that outweighs any natural behaviors now
your brain develops priorities in large
part based on how much dopamine it's
going to get alright so remember the old
show let's make a deal mm-hmm all right
what do you want a hundred dollars or
what's behind door number two there's a
good chance what behind door number two
like a car or something right so they
always pick door number two that's gonna
give you more dopamine all right now
what would you do if something you value
is at risk and your child's life is at
risk they're gonna go after your child
of sure that's gonna give you more
dopamine beyond any moral rational thing
you're going to instinctively save your
child now the thing about drugs is
because they artificially stimulate this
circuit they produce more dopamine than
any other natural behavior any any and
so when we see some poor guy out on the
street who's lost his family his job his
home his money for his drug we say jeez
that looks completely irrational from
the inside it's rational to him or to
you to him to expressional to him
because he's choosing the bigger
dopamine hat it's just as rational as
giving up the hundred dollars for door
number two it feels like the right thing
to do what drug produces the highest
level of dopamine
we know that cocaine produces pretty
high levels heroin produces pretty high
level it's heroin higher than cocaine I
don't think so but heroin does other
things as well which makes it more
addictive than cocaine I had a friend
who committed suicide and he was
thinking 50 vicodins a day that's what
my best friend the world and I took him
to a rehab center in Tarzana 14 days it
was like 400 bucks a day and he was able
to stay disciplined for a while and and
eventually god I was good and he got
back on vicodin couldn't get off I could
and eventually one day May 5th
he's done and obviously he's not here
with us and many people came back said
it was suicide because of him taking too
many mechanism what is it would vicodin
doctors have told me vicodin and heroin
are the two toughest wants to get off of
what's what makes it so tough to get off
of those two things it's twofold its
reward and Punishment the reward is that
when you take it
it not only stimulates dopamine it
stimulates different kinds of pleasure
molecules as well dopamine is a rush of
pleasure it's like the pleasure you feel
when you're excited and enthusiastic
about something
it's a pleasure you feel when you hit
the homerun or score the soccer goal but
there's a different kind of pleasure
there's a contentment pleasure where you
feel like everything in the world is
perfectly okay heroin vicodin the other
opioids they give you both of those and
that's an unbelievably seductive feeling
oh don't any of you both of those I
don't know of any other drug that does I
don't know of any any natural behavior
may be exempt outside of sex that gives
you both of those things and so it's
seductive and it's dangerous that's the
reward the punishment is that if you get
addicted to it and then you stop using
it you go into horrible withdrawal and
it's painful it's a terrible terrible
experience so it's got you on both sides
it's incredible yeah me you so have you
seen a movie Johnny Cash walk the line I
didn't see that oh my gosh I mean that
you missing a few movies right I'm not a
big movie guy you're not a big movie not
a big movie I walk the line mandatory I
mean I think if you went to my school of
psychiatry you would have to watch
the line may be mandatory right before
we study Plato or Aristotle you can
watch movies philosopher Johnny Cash she
had a lot of good philosophies in life
but there's this one scene where he's in
bed and he's trying to go through it and
you're seeing him sweating and the guys
coming from the other side to sell him
the heroin and the drugs that he's
addicted to and his father-in-law comes
out with a shotgun too true you know
scare the other guy it's a real unique
scene because it shows the example of
how it all starts
Lamar Odom did an interview recently and
he said guy asked some a question how
did you get into cocaine and this video
went viral he says he says you know he
was a weak guy you know I still party in
LA I'd go to all these clubs off of
Sunset and he was always everybody was I
was a weak guy he says one day he gets
invited by this swinger couple okay they
invite him over and they say hey we want
you to come over my wife likes you it
was kind of confused like I've never
done this before
so he says then they tell him to try
cocaine he says the first time I tried
cocaine every other time I tried it was
about experiencing what it was like the
first time I did it well is that pretty
common with all of them were not very
common it's very common yes
dopamine responds to novelty it responds
to things and we can relate to that
think about you by I don't know you buy
a new coat it's a beautiful coat you
wear it for the first time it gives you
all kinds of pleasure you're never gonna
get pleasure like that again from where
none note once you do it again you don't
get the same burst to dopamine is it
similar to puppy a lot like your first
puppy love where you is it is it where
that puppy love you're never gonna
experience again or you know it's kind
of like that maybe maybe love is an
amazing thing falling in love is an
amazing thing I think every time we fall
in love the entire world is brand new
I think falling in love is special so
it's different than i yeah I think
falling in love gives you what nothing
else can give you but think about think
about um you're working and get a big
promotion and get a big raise you get
that raise for the first time you see
that big paycheck you got tons of
dopamine second month third month fourth
months little by little things so you
don't
like like if I go from 10 bucks an hour
to 20 bucks an hour to first time I make
six figures or first time I make a
million you think in six figures produce
more dopamine and a million that that's
what you're saying no what I'm saying is
you're not making six figures you're
getting a paycheck every month
gradually it's going out yeah or you
know let's say so when I was a resident
when I was training to be a psychiatrist
I was getting paid very very little then
I became a faculty member and my
paycheck just jumped first time I got
that paycheck I was in seventh heaven
second time I got it oh this is great
third time for by the fifth time I got
the paycheck it was the same old same
old
yeah so it's similar to that when you
get into cocaine or things like that
yeah do they all pretty much fall into
the same category so what is the
difference between the dopamine
experience I have from drugs you know
from sex you know from high from alcohol
how different are those things I would
say the dopamine experience itself is
probably similar but remember the
brain's very complicated and so in
addition to dopamine you've got all
kinds of other chemicals doing their
thing at the same time it's more like a
symphony than a single instrument
playing a tune so what's going to make
all of these different dopaminergic
experiences different are the different
instruments the other neurotransmitters
brain chemicals that are going on so so
for instance if I'm addicted to alcohol
if I'm addicted to cocaine if I'm
addicted to sex I can't have enough sex
I'm a sex addict I'm an alcoholic I'm a
drug addict mm-hmm is it extremely
different or is it there's a lot of
similar there's a lot of similarities
there's a lot of similarities and it's
always chasing what you don't have I
write about a patient in the book who is
a sex addict and you know it's one of
these guys who would go to bars and he'd
pick women up and take him home and he
any sleep with them and what do you what
he started to notice was that as soon as
he had sex with them he completely lost
interest in them they were nothing to
him
after he had achieved that conquest it
was interesting is that that moment when
he lost interest in them became earlier
and earlier and earlier and earlier and
it got to the point where he gave them
his line they agreed to go have sex with
him he lost interest at that moment he
didn't even want to have sex as soon as
the conquest was complete and the sex
was now a sure thing he lost interest in
it and that's the thing about dopamine
dopamine doesn't give us pleasure for
things we have it can only make us want
more so we got the title from the
molecule of more once you get it
dopamine shuts off once you get it
dopamine shuts off so how different is
drugs alcohol sex versus social media
all right well let me let me say a
little bit more about once you get it
dopamine shuts off right because I think
the best way to understand that is with
buyer's remorse you think about
something you were incredibly excited
about buying okay and you imagine it for
example I got a Mazda Miata which I
absolutely love so much fun to drive
before I got that I would spend hours
and hours on the internet reading about
it you know going to these sites where
owners were talking about it and I was
so excited I thought my life is going to
be completely different once I got it I
love this thing I've had it for ten
years it's a wonderful car once I got it
I stopped going on the internet to read
about it I enjoyed it but it was no
longer excitement I didn't exactly have
buyer's remorse but my attitude about it
changed from desire excitement and
enthusiasm there's kind of more of a
quiet enjoyment so let's talk about
social media social media gets you
addicted by always promising you more
there's always this sense if I'm not on
social media I'm gonna miss out on
something I need to get more clicks I
need to get more likes I need to get
more friends if every kind of scrolling
through your social media looking at
these different stories looking at these
different posts
you realize a miserable I should be
doing something else this is boring this
is making me sad but you can't stop
because what you're afraid of is that
there's something down there that might
be important there's something down
there that might give you more might
make your life better and so you just
can't stop and that's dopamine pushing
you along how different is it with when
it was TV and no social media and people
watching TV at night or consuming the
news by reading the newspaper how
different is it today than then the
difference is that the news was almost
never about you social media is all
about you and that gives you the biggest
dopamine hit because remember the point
of dopamine is evolutionary success so
dopamine is always scanning the
environment
what has the potential to influence my
future well-being you look on the news
alright the weather report does you know
the traffic report does maybe there's
something that's going to influence you
but most of it really doesn't influence
you all that much with social media
everything does and that's why you get
so much more of a dopamine hit and why
it can be wonderful it can be
pleasurable we can make all kinds of
great connections but with great power
comes great danger as well what's that
what's the worst danger what's the worst
thing we're that could happen with this
the danger is that it's no longer a tool
to make your life better
it becomes a sink where it absorbs all
of your time all of your focus all of
your energy and everything else around
it shrivels everything around it
shrivels so you stopped paying attention
to the people in your life because all
you're worried about is getting more
dopamine off of social media that's
right it's the holiday season yeah right
we get together with friends and family
this is our chance maybe we only see
them once a year this is our chance to
enjoy them we all pull out our phone
we start scrolling I was doing a radio
interview the other day about the
holidays and the interview one was
telling me about how Christmas had been
a favorite time of year for his mother
and she was gone now and every Christmas
the most meaningful thing he did was
think about her and remember those past
Christmases he had with her it's such a
beautiful thing it's such an important
moment for him and it tells us we've got
to appreciate what we have now there's
gonna come a time when the people we
love are no longer with us we need to
put away our cell phones and make those
memories enjoy them while they're here
those messages have been made over and
over and over again what I'm asking is
what is the worst what are the
consequences of us being addicted to to
social media Instagram Twitter texting
snap all of the youtubes what is the
worst long-term consequences we could
face with this well how about the end of
the human race you think so yeah tell me
why you know earlier we were talking
about the advantage of modern society
compared to ancient society and all the
fantastic stuff that we have right now
we've got so much amazing cool stuff
we've got all kinds of things we can buy
we've got all kinds of things we can
experience we we've got great jobs we do
years and years and years and years of
education something's got a gift what is
it that we're giving up for all of these
things
the answer is children once an economy
reaches a certain point of prosperity
the members of that economy lose
interest in reproducing all of the
developed nations have a negative
population growth rate in order to keep
the human race going
each woman needs to have 2.1 children
two children to replace her and the
father and one to replace people who die
before they have a chance to reproduce
in all developed countries the birth
rate is less than 2.1
even in developing nations we're seeing
this happen it's falling and falling and
falling we don't have a solution there
are some countries where they're now
paying people to have children and even
that's not working as we get more and
more gadgets that attract our attention
they become substitutes for family and
ultimately the human race is simply
going to collapse unless something
changes so interpretation are you trying
to tell everybody that's watching this
to set the phone aside and have sex with
somebody rights exactly what that's what
you're saying
yes more sex is what you're promoting
that's right so so we're going back to
the Woodstock days if just let's get
together have sex with it and listen
promoting I'm not the first one burro
sex in Singapore they had this holiday
called national night it was
co-sponsored by Mentos the freshmaker
and it said let your patriotism explode
when you come back the question is if
bumble is there and if tinder is there
that's the biggest factor we have to
make sure you can still swipe right or
left over there let me go back to what
you're saying in all seriousness ok so
this could cause us to not have enough
babies ok we need to have 2.1 babies to
continue the number and everybody right
now is less than 2.1 now the argument on
the opposite side I hear a lot of people
saying is we're having way too many
babies what if eventually we are
overpopulated then what happens I mean
you got climate change people talking
about the fact that the more population
we have reducing carbon dioxide that's
not good because of the whole you know
the theory a greenhouse you know the
whole theory about the fact that Suns
coming in and it's going out and it's
getting thicker so it's staying in here
that's getting a hotter climates
changing so your argument as complete
opposite we need to keep having babies
because people are saying let's not
because China right now you're limited
you can't have I think their limit is to
one baby per family right now
they changed it when did they change it
they changed it some time ago because
what they realized was
they were getting negative population
growth the problem with negative
population growth is you need young
workers to support the older retired
people who are drawing pensions and what
happened with China with their one-child
policy is that they now realize they
don't have enough young people to
support the pensions of the older people
is this a recent thing like five ten
year thing because at least ten years at
least at least 10 years so but yeah am I
am I allowed to have as many as I can I
believe so and in fact I believe check
that car real quick I'm actually really
I think the Chinese government has
actually done a 180 degrees and they're
not encouraging people to have more
children at it that is amazing because
you're gonna get social unrest otherwise
how are you going to pay the pensions of
all these old people somebody may say
they got one and a half billion people
their dough they've got a lot of people
but for for an economy to grow you've
got to have a growing population so so
what what the the number you're saying
is 2.1 you know but you're saying
they're not having more kids today
because we are on the phones all the
time and even at night if are on your
bed you're looking at your phone many
people are falling asleep watching their
phones so the last thing you're thinking
about is what hey babe you want to mess
around or something and you're already
too tired to have sex because either she
fell asleep or you fell asleep on your
phone so that's causing it to be like
and I tell you what the bigger problem
is it's pornography pornography is so
easily available today and it is an
addictive thing as well when I was a kid
growing up if you want to pornography
you're doing the drugstore pick up a
magazine and hope the person across the
counter wasn't a member of the Agassi
what was yours but I tell you one time
i'ma say the funniest story one time my
I come home I'm 1314 years old and you
know where you hide the penthouse you
know you're sure so my mom comes and
she's crying uh-huh and I said why are
you crying she says I just saw something
it's
it's I'm very disappointed in you I said
what are you disappointed CISO she says
come with me so I go to the room and I
see all my best pictures sitting on top
of my bed boy says what is this I said
mom what do you want me to masturbate to
these are my favorite I said don't even
wrinkle that one that's one of my
favorite one so I started setting them
aside and she was nice enough to not
tear em apart but I had to find a
different place to hide it so kids if
you're watching it's a good place to
hide I don't know if you've done this
one or not the drawer you know the box
yeah it's much better I've used that one
my mom knew the bottom drawer so I had
to get good tape and you all enjoyed on
under what he called it so this is the
yellow the bottom of the drawer I tape
it right here yeah I ever found it again
legit place that's a tip right there for
you by the way don't tell you mom and
dad parents make sure they don't watch
it and then one day she took it a good
well but okay so I agree that you know
because porn is more available today and
by the way you know yesterday's video we
were making we're making a funny video
about the whole annual review I was
telling you about one of the examples
was a watching porn at work as crazy as
this sounds I cannot tell you how many
people I've ran I ran sales offices for
20 years I'd walk into one of my sales
bases office like buddy over here
honestly you know what are you just so
you really in the mood but even in this
stall you're sitting there and you know
you're the next person makes you in the
stall you're that's a bathroom right now
so ha I agree with you so what is the
worst effects that porn can have want on
our lives right so so pornography
stimulates dopamine just like drugs and
and food and all these other things and
you know when when we talk about people
being addicted to something what we
wanted us to look at the influence it
has on their life is it taking up large
amounts of time in which they could be
doing something else is it interfering
and of course pornography does that
people get addicted they'll spend hours
and hours per day is interfering with
relationships with pornography it's it's
a big yes people who spend too much time
watching pornography they have trouble
performing with regular sex and the
reason is that just like with alcohol
you might
start out with beer maybe some wine you
progress to hard liquor mixed drinks and
finally you just drinking the money
right out of the bottle
same with pornography you start out with
tame stuff and little by little you go
up to more and more extreme acts when
you're with the real human being it just
doesn't do it anymore
and so a lot of people have erectile
dysfunction they don't even want to have
sex with real people
one guys quoted as saying I'd rather
stay at home and look at pornography and
then go out on a date because the
pornography woman never says no and she
never asked it just but I heard it so
many times you're not the only person
saying this so I've had buddies say like
you know Pamela Anderson did an
interview on porn have you seen this one
I haven't seen it's incredible the way
Pamela if you watched it I'd love to
have you here and talk about this topic
because I think so many young men can
learn from the way she described it she
says so one day she talks to her son
about sex because you know the whole
poor situation so she says I'm out there
dating and all of a sudden I'm going out
there and I'm going on dating I'm having
sex and guys are trying stuff on me and
they're slapping I'm like I don't like
that and they're trying things thinking
that's what women's women was what they
see in a porn thinking that's exactly
what everybody wants to do and then when
they do somebody's disappointed not
realizing these are professional porn
star I ran a gym in Chatsworth okay I
don't know if you know Chatsworth the 20
years ago was the 80% of porn was
producing Chatsworth 80% of porn in us
whatever porn people watch 80% was in
producing Chatsworth so I'm the weekend
manager a chance for and I'm shutting
down the gym these porn stars would come
to me and they would say hey man you
know can I use the gym I do we just want
to do a quick 30-minute shoot at the end
you know hey I'd be in the pool there
having sex there meets all over the
place we'd have to send these guys from
all the time obviously my young guys Oh
everybody wondered stick or enjoy it and
I want to do participate and contribute
to society well our stars but I
mentioned it's not that sexy though when
you're actually seeing the porn stars
shoot on the set a when you're 21 full
of testosterone it is good in our
recession it's good it's very sexy some
of us were you're taking notepads and
trying to take notes but
but the point is the sex would pornstars
with the camera off is just a you know
different than a sex with you know on
camera so a lot of soap and lanterns
selling Sun st. listen if you're gonna
have sex with your girl just know all
these are the things you saw there she's
probably not gonna like it
okay so if you want to ask ask first if
she likes it before you do because you
may have liked all of us if you if
you've dated if you've been with you
know many sexual partners you'll always
come across to one that likes to be
hanging off the table and rope and
freaking hit me with this and I want you
to bring this you know all these weird
things to use I had a very interesting
girl friend of mine in army that liked a
lot of extracurricular activities but
then you realize most of them are not
really that's really a kind of stuff so
porn completely disappoints the man
thinking girls want to do that so what
is the biggest threat with porn when
virtual reality and augmented reality
comes out yeah I mean you're sitting
there and you watching a porn what
effects you think this is gonna have
long-term same thing kids not going on
dates it's gonna make it worse and worse
and worse yeah we're gonna get the
virtual reality it's gonna become
increasingly more real and we're gonna
have it's gonna create unrealistic
expectations just as pornography has
create this unrealistic expectation for
Pamela Anderson's son it's gonna be like
Netflix Netflix [ __ ] knows what kind of
movies you like these porn channels are
gonna learn what kind of women you like
what you like the women to do and it's
gonna know you so well that no
flesh-and-blood human being is going to
be able to compete with the pixels and
we're gonna be less and less interested
in human beings and more and more
interested in pixels do you think so I
think so yeah III hopefully things will
get bad enough that we'll begin to
realize hey this is a dangerous thing
we've got to start looking at this the
way we look at alcohol and cocaine and
realize that this
taps into our brain in such a powerful
primitive way that it's going to destroy
our life and yeah I think so yeah I mean
so you go back to biblical times they
would talk about the city of Corinth
right you know they say the oldest
occupation in the world you know what it
is restitution rights all right so is
this really something that is a new
thing that we're gonna experience and
it's gonna really have that kind of a
dramatic effect because you know
sometimes my concern is you when when we
go and we sell fear obviously we all
know fewer sells dramatically for
yourselves when the market tanks
infomercial guys are blown out because
they know how to sell anything during
that time because fewer sharpens
listening when you're afraid you listen
sometimes I think we have to be a little
bit more careful in this you could
disagree with me on this because
sometimes we we turned something as a
crisis into an 18 year old thinking
about it so because they think it's even
a bigger problem sometimes they even get
more obsessed about it and in their mind
they think it's going to be terrible for
them versus not even paying attention to
something a little bit just kind of
telling them to you listen it is
something you got to be careful with and
then eventually it phases out my dad I
would tell my dad about my kid I say you
know look I'm having very probably a big
problem my son right now
my first son he says what is the problem
I said you know I see you know he
wouldn't pick up after his stuff to you
the day it was really but it says he's a
year and a half what are you talking
about and so then he got two and a half
years old I had a different problem like
I don't know I just I'm concerned
because you know when I tell him what to
do you know he's just you was
two-and-a-half years old then he you
know I don't know it when I talk to him
sometimes I don't think he's really
talking to me and it could he's four
years old so every time that I thought
something was an issue it lasted two
three four five six months and it went
away and it went away because he
graduated that and sometimes for us go
back and think about the biggest thing
you had to overcome when you were a kid
or I was a kid so we were like oh
somebody thought we're never gonna get
rid of it yeah and then eventually got
rid you think sometimes we have to alter
be help to help the responsible to not
make a turn
all hills into a mountain because the
next generation is going to have a
unnecessary fear injected into them that
could prevent them from fulfilling their
own life what do you think about that
well you know I think you make a very
good point if I sound like I'm on
shrooms just say hi if I have a point it
just tell me I have a pool I think
you've got a point I think that human
beings have good sense and a lot of
times the good sense wins over our
destructive instinctual reactions but
look at cigarettes for example
cigarettes are a terrible product
they're extremely addictive and they
kill you absolutely right more than
marijuana by the way yeah that's right
that's right now at some point we as a
society realized or decided whether
we're I don't know if we're right we
said we have to start putting some
restrictions on cigarettes because the
product is simply too dangerous nicotine
to drug it stimulates dopamine
stimulates it too hard and so when
people get addicted they lose control we
kind of felt like the basic good sense
that human beings have is no match for
this terribly addictive drug let me tell
you why I think pornography might lead
us in this direction let's say that we
had two women one was beautiful one was
kind of plain one cared about your
happiness more than anything else the
other was a normal selfish human being
you don't go for the beautiful one that
cared about you
now what if she was a robot would that
matter to you 100% it would absolutely
what let's say that physically she was
indistinguishable no because of feelings
to me I see where you're going with this
because feelings to me to know that I
sincerely believe you chose to love me
and accept me matters to me rather than
fabricating that feeling by recoding you
in a way where you love me just because
I quoted you properly the robot would
love anybody but the human being is the
only gonna love you
I think that that's a very good point I
mean there are things thing about human
beings that are unfathomable depths and
if anything's gonna save us that's
what's gonna save us
those unfathomable depths that you can't
get from a computer they did different
way of watching porn
I mean people reviewing porn so look if
you're watching this interview and
watching porn turn off the porn I'm just
telling you turn the porn off and pay
attention to the interview here so okay
so we've gone drugs
we've gone alcohol we've gone sex did we
really go into sex and depth we kind of
thought we did we did you love though
okay let's go a lot let's go Bumstead
love is very different than everything
else so yeah so what's on your mind with
you Bob
Carl confuses the hell out of all of us
we become different human beings oh yeah
some people say that love is the most
intensely pleasurable experience that
human beings have oh and we're talking
about falling in love we might call it
passionate love you know you see so many
movies about it so many books about it
it plays a very very central role and
and when you fall in love you feel like
the world is brand-new it's a very
dopaminergic experience and that's a
wonderful thing but the problem with
love of course is that it doesn't last
and people always want to try to make
this passionate love last and they can't
do it and a lot of people don't
understand that and they think that when
the passionate love comes to an end on
average it lasts 12 months when the
passionate love comes to an end
it means the relationship has come to an
end something has gone wrong in the
relationship one things we write about
in the book is that's not true that's
simply the normal way the brain works
passionate love lasts about a year and
then it turns into something different
it turns into something called
companionate love it's no longer using
dopamine dopamine is about excitement
it's about more it's about the future
that's what passionate love is you know
rosy future happily ever after my life
is never going to be the same
companionate though uses pleasure
chemicals in the brain
that are about the present moment it's
about satisfaction and contentment it's
about the deep satisfaction of having
another person's life deeply entwined
with your own so when you fall in love
you got to be ready for that shift you
got to look for it when it comes and say
yeah it's sad that the roller coaster
ride if passionate love is over but this
is a deeper more enduring love that in
some ways is a better ride than the
roller coaster you know most people
can't comprehend what you just said it's
a very deep topic what you just said
because you know the whole idea of
newness right mm-hmm you have sex with
somebody like that the moment you date
somebody and let you see guys get sexual
what time you get off work
you want to go to lunch over here I'll
pick you up so it's gonna you have a car
you're going to backseat and you do that
for the first 90 days and then yeah
you're having sex but not like before
then 12 months later it's not anymore
now you're like hey what's up yeah you
know what I'm good I'm tired and I'm
just gonna stay in right and then you go
to the next one wanting to chase the
next thing that experienced it and a lot
of time and marriage this comes to a
eventual point where it's tough to kind
of make the marriage work what do you do
when you get to that point where you sit
there and you say I am I have I love you
but I'm no longer in love with you
you've heard that statement yes right
well glad I say I say so what's
happening between the two of you guys
Pat I'm not gonna lie to you man I love
I love her a lot
I'm just not in love with her anymore
like I once was what does that mean when
people say that to you well that's
normal that's what happens to everybody
and we just are our brains were simply
not wired to have this in love feeling
last forever you know companion it comes
from the word friend companion and so
you don't have this person you're
absolutely insane over and by the way
there is a way to bring back sparkles of
that passion of love which we can talk
about but it's not an everyday thing but
instead what you have is this loyal deep
friendship with another person and
that's a pretty nice thing to have
loyal deep friendship with another
person how does one in that moment know
the fact that whoever else you date a
year later is gonna become not
passionate love companion love how do
you decipher between the two it's a very
hard thing to do
yeah you know what is the divorce rate
right now in America fifty percent about
fifty percent okay that's yeah there you
know so what do we have what are we
getting wrong in this place because
you've got one community that saying man
is not built to be monogamous right it's
not I'm not built to be with one person
I don't know if you've seen you have to
make the argument it's a very good
argument he makes and then you have
what's wrong by the way yeah so tell me
more yeah can i I interrupted you
alright go ahead yes it's wrong it's
wrong
human beings have a very strong mating
for life instinct just like swans and
prairie voles it's not perfect you know
we have divorce we have infidelity but
if you the World Health Organization
looked at global statistics and they
found out that by the age of 50 more
than 90 percent of people all over the
world have been married at least once
now that's not to say that they are
absolutely faithful but marriage is an
intention to have one individual for
life and ninety percent of us at some
point in our life at least had that
intention and many of us kept it have we
kept it because we want to keep it or
have we kept it because of some kind of
a church or a belief that has made it
but made us believe that it's the right
thing to do we're at some point this
religion was used in a way to control
the populace of not you know pissing off
each other and I don't flirt with your
wife because natural instinct if I mess
with your wife you're gonna be upset at
me if you flirt with my wife I'm going
to be upset out with you upset at you is
it a natural from us or how much of it
is an institution or church or religion
pass it down to us where we believe that
do you think well you know what I'm
asking you I do know address yeah
human beings are incredibly complicated
you know inside our head we think
there's one person
me but it's actually the seething
cauldron of competing motivations and
goals so we talked about drugs the drug
addict wants his cocaine the drug also
wants to be a good father now a lot of
the time the cocaine is gonna win but
we've got these competing drives so when
you get married there's a big part of
you that wants to be a good husband for
the rest of your life but you can't help
it you're a human being you got these
competing drives that you see a pretty
woman and you want to have sex with her
so we've got these things like the
church our community our government that
have been built up to support one of
these drives and if we don't think
that's the right thing nobody keeps us
in the church these days you know in the
old days if you want to be part of
society you had to go to the church or
the synagogue the mosque
these days it's much more of a choice a
lot of people choose to do it though
because they're identifying with one of
those competing drives they're saying
that yeah I know I've got these these
interests and other women but I don't
like that part of myself I like the good
husband part of myself and so I'm gonna
surround myself with these institutions
that's going to help me stay a good
husband and I think that they're acting
prudently because how many people have
an extramarital affair and two years
later say best thing I ever did
yeah you don't hear that you don't hear
that oh we know it's not a good idea
just like we know eating that third
donut is not such a good idea it's a
primitive Drive that doesn't necessarily
have our future happiness in mind when
it makes us eat that third donut or have
the extra marital what a way of you put
it oh my gosh so the three institutions
you said a church a religion the
government what was the other one you
saw community your community yeah
powerful very powerful what you just
said right there regarding anything else
you have to share on the love side yeah
there was something I wanted to say just
give me a second we can come back if it
comes back let's come back to you no
problem because that topic is a
it's a deep topic let's go into politics
okay so politics for me is and then and
then we'll go into domination because
I'm curious to know what you're gonna
say with mother I haven't even gone
through my notes just the conversation
alone I'm enjoying it's just so you
notice and the I told you earlier Daniel
Lieberman you know there's two of you
that's right so in both of you guys
professor so it's kind of like you know
it's conflict and which is which but I
know you've done your own speeches and
his but the next one is politics you
know for me sometimes I look at people
and I say you just feel like a liberal
to me okay in my mind and I'll see
someone else I'll just say you feel like
a conservative to me and I'll see
someone I'll say you're an independent
you trying to play it safe you just kind
of trying to stay in the middle neutral
you don't want arguments you just kind
of run I totally understand I respect
your point I respect your point right
and it doesn't take long to realize if
somebody's a Democrat or a Republican or
liberal or a you know conservative it
doesn't take hard few minutes of
conversations you can kind of figure out
where people are leaning it's not hard
to ask those questions I've asked this
question from Jordan Peterson I've asked
it from so many different people myself
I'm piercing to what your answer is
gonna be are we born somewhat liberal or
you know and are we born some of us from
the day we're born we're liberals a part
of us and we're conservative a part of
it so what are your thoughts on that I
think the answer is yes but I think it's
a very very small tendency and the
reason why I say that is that if you
look at individuals it's very very
difficult if not impossible to find
something they're born with that is
leading them to a particular political
ideology but if you look at very very
large groups of people mm-hmm thousands
of people yeah little tiny things will
come out in the averages and we can see
that we can see that people will have
different kinds of upbringing as people
have different kinds of genes there are
very very subtle influences that we can
bring out in the averages so it's not
genes because so you're saying it's a
small percentage it's a small percentage
yeah but it is genes yeah because for me
I said I say a guy asked me one time how
do we come
political beliefs I said this and tell
me if you agree with this or if you see
it's different
one is a cultural you were born
Christian your parameter you were
involved in a Christian Church and
everybody there was conservative so he
kind of grew up in that environment so
tradition the other one is you had a
falling-out with somebody your dad was a
Republican he made a lot of money but
wasn't around so you become a Democrat
because you hate Republicans because all
they care about is money or you grew up
in a family that was a Democrat that
we're all you know let's just say
financially they weren't doing well and
they were just kind of voting for a
certain party and you're like okay I
don't want to go that right because I
don't want to live that life I'm gonna
go be a Republican so you fight whatever
somebody let down let you down in your
life so you go and become the opposite
that somebody does you hear this very
comment with some names then the other
one is somebody took a liking into you
you grew up with not even any political
beliefs a coach like your professor like
your teacher like you and they became a
father figure or mother figure that you
didn't have in your life and they happen
to be a Republican they happen to be a
Democrat and you say no one in my life
has been this interested in me as this
man is I'm loyal to his beliefs I'm
gonna be a Republican and then there's
people that just kind of want to they
had a big life-changing event that
happened to them you were in your house
and somebody came in and shot you with a
gun and you didn't like guns and now you
say everybody needs to have a gun
because I got to protect myself no one
will ever come and shoot somebody and my
father or somebody anytime ago so a
life-changing event that takes place
would you say there's any other things
outside of that that determine end up
somebody being a liberal or conservative
well first of all I think you make a
great point that we believe that our
political views are based on reason but
reason probably plays a very small role
it's the things you mentioned and
sometimes you see videos on YouTube
where they go people on streets and they
read them something that a politician
said and they say what do you think
about that I I agree completely it said
well it turns out it was said by someone
on the other side of the spectrum is you
see well I disagree completely but you
know I'm I'm gonna go on a limb and I'm
gonna say I think biology has something
to do with it tell me why so you know it
comes back to the whole thing about the
brain chemicals
we've talked a lot about dopamine sure
dopamine looks to the future getting
more making the future a better place we
haven't spoken quite as much on what we
call the hearing now neurotransmitters
those the neurotransmitters that help us
to experience the present and typically
what we experience in the present are
sensory inputs which you see hear taste
smell touch emotions and interpersonal
relationships so some of those chemicals
are going to be oxytocin and Dorff an
endocannabinoid if you are born where
the future-oriented
dopamine circuits are a little bit
stronger you're more likely to be
liberal if you're born with hearing now
circuits are a little bit stronger
you're more likely to be conservative
and again it's a small piece but if you
look at large groups of people you can
see the differences very interesting can
you talk about what you write about in
your book when you said in Hollywood
they measure to see what percentage of
money was given to Obama versus Romney
the numbers are astronomically different
can you elaborate on that on how that
comes about yeah so there are some
people who we might call dopaminergic
all right these are people who are very
much focused on the future
your listeners I think tend to be very
dopaminergic they're entrepreneurs it
takes an enormous amount of motivation
an enormous amount of drive to be an
entrepreneur
I tried by the way and I failed which is
great experience and so it makes you
more dopaminergic where else do we see
dopaminergic people
well Hollywood they're not entrepreneurs
as much we're seeing a different kind of
dopaminergic person people in Hollywood
are notorious for excess right they
always want more it's never good enough
it doesn't matter how many starring
roles you've been in you always need to
have another it doesn't matter how many
mansions you have around the world you
always need another one we're talking
about marriage and how the divorce rate
among the general population is 50%
during the first five years of marriage
in Hollywood the divorce rate is 80
percent because it's never good enough
right is it because it's never good
enough or is it because temptation is
all around you it's probably a little
bit of both yeah but I think it's more
it's never good enough so Hollywood is a
very dopaminergic place and we clearly
see that there is a strong bias towards
the left in Hollywood almost all of the
financial donations that were given were
given to Democrats
same thing in Silicon Valley this is
where we see the dopaminergic
entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley they
give all their money to the Democrats as
well and very little to the Republicans
interesting why is that dope liberals
have a name for themselves they call
themselves progressives liberalism is
about making the world a better place
the criticism of it is that they try to
make the world a better place by
achieving utopia and the only way you
can do that is by having total control
over society but but the goal is to make
the world a better place to plan our
cities so that they will be less
polluting and easier to get around to
determine what kind of education our
children need to tell people hey you
gotta wear helmets when you ride your
motorcycle to say our health care system
is not working let the government take
it over because the government knows
better and the government will fix it
it's about progress and that's a very
dopaminergic thing so where you find
dopaminergic people Hollywood Silicon
Valley academia you find people who lean
towards the progressive side of the
political ideology how about the other
way round the other way around are
people who are more focused on the here
and now you see they're more likely to
be conservatives what does the word
conservative mean it means keeping what
we've inherited from our forebears and
not letting it change conserve so it's
the opposite of dopaminergic change you
see this these days especially among
blue-collar workers that segment of our
country feels like things are changing
too fast
I can't keep up with all of these these
politically collect rules I have to
follow I can't keep up with you know
there used to be two genders then maybe
there were three four now nobody knows
how many genders there are they feel
like things are moving too fast and
they're there the brakes the Liberals
are the accelerator in the car and the
Conservatives are the brakes they're
saying hold on a minute let's not lose
all of the good things we've inherited
from the people who came before us you
know who then is Prager is mmhmm yeah
it's pretty clear once said
conservatives are wise liberals are
smart he says I've never met a liberal
who is wise there's no wisdom on the
left there are a lot of say that I you
can say that you seriously think there's
I don't know it I don't say it I know it
I lived it I went to Columbia my
professors were brilliant and had almost
no wisdom so you're saying the left is
smart the writers wise yes you're really
saying that yes that's exactly the
people the ideas what do you think about
what he's saying yeah you know on
average liberals do have a higher IQ
than conservatives it's not much it's
just a few points and again it's an
average but what is IQ measuring like
you is measuring a dopaminergic ability
to figure out problems your IQ will
predict how well you do in school
it will also predict how well how much
money you make in your career but it
does not predict how happy you're going
to be having high IQ doesn't help you
decide who to be friends with it doesn't
help you decide who to marry it doesn't
help you decide where to live these are
things that are not subject to IQ so you
know what liberals have higher IQs than
conservatives the Conservatives are
happier is this actual proven stuff yeah
yeah it's calop insanely yeah
we've got Gallup polls that show Oh dad
that if you if you if we get the link I
want to put if you want to see the link
we'll get the link will be a long way to
see that's right so conservative
to live happier lives then liberals do
even though liberals on average have a
higher IQ than conservatives do yes
that's right
and it makes sense because if you want
if you're very dopaminergic interesting
to me I mean I'm already like I'm still
thinking about it
go go ahead keeps it if you're a very
dopaminergic and you want to change the
world happiness is your enemy you you
were talking about what if everybody is
content nothing happens
only some people in our society can be
content
we need the unhappy dissatisfied people
to move us forward so I think it's time
to smoke weed so if you want to light it
up a little too deep right now with
these conversations but okay that's very
interesting with the political side any
other research or studies you did on the
politics side that you know gave you
some kind of a trend to say this is
another thing that we can talk about to
to learn about the whole liberals and
conservatives yeah we looked at some
very interesting research that showed
ways in which scientists could actually
manipulate people's political beliefs
and make them either more conservative
or more liberal scientists yeah how what
ways that you would be very surprised
let me let me talk about ways in which
they were able to make liberal people
more conservative they took a bunch of
students and they had them fill out
these questionnaires looking at their
political ideology and they could give
them a score how liberal how
conservative they were they invited up
into two groups one group they had it
fill it out and there was a hand
sanitizer nearby the presence of the
hand sanitizer made the more
conservative the presence of their hand
sanitizer made them old conservative
that's right the other group there's no
hand sanitizer on average this group
filled out their questionnaire in a more
conservative way than the other group
did why is that the reason is the hand
sanitizer is a sign of threat it reminds
you that you are at risk of becoming
infected
it's a tiny subtle intervention but it
reflects a much larger intervention that
we
understand terrorists attack make the
country more conservative if there's an
election coming up and there's a
terrorist attack around the time of the
election the polls shift in favor of the
Conservatives because when you feel
under threat you say I need to protect
what I have it's when you feel safe you
say let's take some risks let's make the
world a better place
that's dopamine and just the hands now
what's funny is election seasons in
November yeah that's flu season so when
you go to your polling place you might
see a little thing a hand sanitizer
sitting on the table I don't think they
know the RNC or the DNC is watching this
used to get a bunch and sanitizer a
new-look polling right outside here
looking for some hand sanitizer in the
DNC's got to pull all that stuff out
that's right I once said that when you
go to the bathroom you know the signs
that said employees must wash their
hands those are those advertisers for
the Republicans are you kidding me who
did this study I camera in the book it's
in the book crazy to me now we can do it
in the other direction too so different
different group of scientists very
similar kind of questionnaire and they
told people imagine that you have
superpowers and nothing can hurt you
yeah I just want you to spend five
seconds just imagining you have
superpowers and nothing can hurt you
shifts people are more liberal because
it's the opposite you take the threat
away a lot of conservatives have fears
our immigrants going to change the
country
how are people who are different from me
going to threaten my way of life if you
can lower those fears they will be come
in in subtle ways not traumatic but in
subtle ways more liberal who's better
for society or they're both need each
other we need both the Harz need both an
accelerator and a break we need that
ballot there with you yeah I fully
that's what you have a left wing and a
right wing I think that's right I'm
fully with you on on this so
like currently right now would
impeachment is the is the wise decision
being made or the smart decision being
made you know we're talking about Theory
when theory turns into practice it
becomes much more complicated because
opinions tied to it or there's just so
many other things at stake
so he's impeaching the president a
liberal thing to do or is it a
conservative thing to do is it
dopaminergic thing to do is it here and
now thing to do it's just a game of
power you know a lot of people will say
well this is my political ideology they
get to Washington DC and a lot of times
it just becomes about what's convenient
what will get me power what will get me
reelected you know we saw the Tea Party
come out because what the Conservatives
were for last time you heard about him
you haven't heard about him for eight
years haven't heard him out for a long
time yeah Michelle Bachman all those
guys that were coming up yeah yeah yeah
but they came for a reason the reason
they came is because conservative voters
elected Republican politicians the
Republican politicians went to
Washington and behaved in liberal ways
they expanded the government they raised
taxes then the Tea Party said we're
electing you guys and you're you're
growing the government and so the point
is that when you have real people doing
real things theory breaks down when you
have real people doing real things
Theory breaks down yeah and I wonder how
many times like that one party is
mimicked in the other side's habits and
they don't even know they're doing it
yeah you know what I'm so you're gonna
do this to me I'm gonna do this to you
but you're doing the retaliation is not
your way of doing things
you're retaliating like a liberal or
you're retaliating like a conservative
because you're mimicked in what they're
doing to you and so it's a form of
revenge we were not being true to your
own way of thinking that's that's
exactly right you react
instead of act out of reason you react
out of emotion yeah because sometimes
you're like they're not acting like
liberals they're acting like
conservatives they're not acting like
conservatives all right they're like
what the hell is going you're confused
sometimes nowadays you used to defend a
war now you're not defend
the warning used to say the war is bad
now you want to do more war what's going
on over here and it's it's a m'as and a
bit of their identity sometimes dancing
I mean the theory of the Republic is
that we we elect people to represent our
views but how many laws are passed the
majority of Americans don't want yes
okay so let me ask you so you got people
that come out of high school people go
to college and there's those that say I
just want to go make my money make
millions leave me alone I'm gonna be a
libertarian whatever I'm just gonna go
do that part and then there are those
that go into politics and they say oh
yeah here's how I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna have control and the laws I'm
gonna make and I'm gonna be able to get
to control people with the decisions
that I want to make and I'm gonna go
this side now some people go into
politics to want to do good but some
people go into politics for power versus
freedom do you see a trend with people
who chase money they're typically
seeking freedom versus those who chase
power they're seeking no choice politics
they're more seeking power do you do you
notice that because sometimes you're
from academia okay so I went to Harvard
OPM program okay and OPM program you
know what the program is is the owner
president management program you have to
do certain amount of top-line revenue
and they bring people from 60 plus
countries 140 CEOs founders who kind of
spent three weeks together on campus so
I went there and I experienced what it
was like to be on a campus and I watched
all the professor's 90% of them were all
liberal I won during the time where
Trump and Hillary were debating one of
the debates I was there at the chow hall
with a thousand of them and not one
person was yeah you know very great
everybody oh you're such a dish you're a
bigot it was crazy I'm just kind of
sitting or watching everybody
just to kind of get a feel so to me
sometimes I wonder if academia and
politics they're going to have power and
decision making process to see that they
can have a little bit of control over
you and the guys that go on the money
and a you know business side they're
just kind of trying to be like leave me
alone do you see that as a trend with
the wiring or not really yeah
I think the academia is a little more
complicated if we have time we gonna do
it yeah but let's just talk about
politicians and business people okay so
somebody starts a business they want
that business to grow and be successful
of course they do there's absolutely no
question about that right somebody goes
into government they want the government
to grow and be successful
and so I think that there is naturally
going to be some conflict between the
two of them because people go look let's
let's let's take the best view of this
we can people go into government to make
the world a better place if you don't
have power you can't make the world a
better place they believe that or that
is the truth well let's give them the
benefit of the doubt
okay you know not all of them do but
again I think they going for the right
cause Bob yeah I mean he actually humans
are complicated there's both I mean
there's both yeah yeah so they want to
grow the governments that they will have
the power the levers to make the world a
better place they need to collect taxes
in order to spend money on building
roads and bridges and and so they want
to collect more taxes so they can build
more roads and bridges the people who
are running their own business though
they want the opposite they say look all
your taxes all of your laws all of your
regulations are making it impossible for
me to be successful leave me alone give
me my freedom so I think in some ways
they both want the same thing they want
to maximize the good they do while
they're on this earth but at the same
time they're in conflict who gets in the
way of the other person - most I'm not
sure about that
you're not sure about that I'm not sure
about really you're not sure about what
the government's probably going to get
in the way more just because the
government has a monopoly on power of
course they do if you're not doing what
it likes they can use force the UM the
business people can use I mean a
negative review on Yelp for congressmen
does what nothing yeah a negative review
for a small restaurant business owner
look what it does to them we can put
them out of business
yeah you can go to DMV and
about the receptionist sucked no one's
gonna read about inch you can go to
restaurants say their waiter was
terrible his name is John Doe that guy's
fired yeah it's gonna get written up so
you know it's interesting on the
perspective there I'll tell you an
advantage business house though tell me
so government is rigid and inflexible
there's basically one idea and it's
tough to move it's tough to move and
when you pass a law either it works or
it doesn't if it works is terrific if it
doesn't it's terrible
with businesses you've got a hundred
businesses starting up 99 of them fail
and so you've got all of these ideas
being tried out all kinds of flexibility
all kinds of variety so I think that's
the advantage of business you got a
whole lot more flexibility you've got
the ability to try thousands of ideas
and pick one that works and let all of
the others fail yeah I'm and that's a
good point you know an old colleague of
mine called me and I had a lengthy
conversation very successful guy while I
was in Detroit he said you know Pat you
got to realize I'm not an entrepreneur
like you he works for a very big company
that's controlled by him that's
controlled by very big company and he
said I want to come up with an idea it's
gonna take me six to 12 months to get
somebody look I gotta go committee
committee committee committee committee
yeah you guys come up with an idea on
where you can execute it the name same
day or the next day you have that so and
it's okay if it fails it's okay if it
fails and in the end the thing that's
happening which is kind of a is a lot of
a lot of these too big to fail companies
are starting to become governments of
their own that's right and they're
experiencing that with in and it kind of
hurts the people that are the
entrepreneur thinking within it and
they're either leaving or the kind of
gonna have to say look I have to kind of
figure this out and stay here ya know
what's gonna happen so last thing that I
want to talk to you about you talk about
domination in the book and dopamine Y
domination and dopamine I mean how do
those go together yeah so a dopamine is
all about maximizing future resources
now we've mainly been and there's
different circuits in the brain that use
dopamine we've mainly been focusing on
the circuit we call the desire circuit
that's the thing that makes you want
things it gives you energy and
motivation something that makes you want
the don't
and the sex guy there's a different
circuit though that we call the control
circuit and from an evolutionary point
of view it's a newer circuit it goes up
here in the frontal lobes and it takes a
longer-term view of the future so the
desire circuit may say I want to eat
that doughnut the control circuit may
say you know what that might make us
happy for about 30 seconds but if we
look ahead a month a year five years
from now we're going to be better off
not eating that doughnut so it's the
control circuit that gives us a much
more sophisticated way of maximizing our
future resources and it allows us to use
tools like abstractions such as science
mathematics language and this is what we
really see the powerful tools the human
brain has for changing the world and
making it better please go ahead
and that's that's about domination we're
using this long term sophisticated
control circuit to absolutely dominate
our environment to dominate our
environment or dominate an industry or
same thing it's really about dominating
our environment dopamine always wants
more so it's really about squeezing as
much resources as we possibly can think
about what science does in terms of our
ability to get calories out of an acre
of land with every agricultural
advancement we're growing more and more
food in smaller and smaller areas it's
getting the most we can out of our
environment what do you put the people
that become heavy-duty world leaders are
they more dopamine driven or what makes
them want to go through the pain of
being a world leader or president
whether you put Hillary there or bill
there or Donald Trump there or Obama or
Reagan or Bush or you know or some of
the even world leaders on the other end
I mean Aragon from Turkey and some of
these guys have become dictators what
causes someone to want to have that kind
of power and influence and put their
body through and their emotions through
the pain that comes with it yeah it's
brutal its dopamine what what is
dopamine yeah I said they just wanted at
the highest loved it wondered more than
everybody else yeah that's what they
want power more they
I mean you look at these leaders they
are not happy most of you look at XI the
leader of China boy what a miserable
experience that's gotta be right I mean
he's he's trying to keep absolute
control things could fall apart at any
moment he's got to deal with the trade
dispute with Hong Kong he's got all of
these things it's got to be absolutely
miserable why would anyone want to be
that unhappy and why would you sacrifice
everything for that level of an
unhappiness it's not reason it's
instinct it's brain chemicals as
primarily dopamine it's instinct
so I want more power I want more control
and let me ask you does it when if
somebody is more driven by a communistic
philosophy then the democracy that we
have here does that mean the person of
communistic philosophy wants even more
power and control than another person or
you it's hard to say it's hard to say I
think that people view communism in
different ways I mean ideally when you
have communism the government is
supposed to shrivel up and dry off right
right after I mean I think that's what
Karl Marx said once communism is
perfected it's not policy of course not
but but I think that yeah it's not
possible is not possible
no it's not possible because because
everybody is I just had a conference
call right now okay right before you and
when you were out there I was just doing
a conference call and the conference
call that I had was my with my main guys
not my executives because we have a
couple hundred executives it was with my
vice presidents these are guys that are
all making very good money for them so
it's ranging from a quarter million to a
couple million ooh they're doing good
for themselves and the conversation went
about you know why are you waiting on me
like this is you you take the lead and
do this part not a lot of them we're
doing the right thing so it's not
everybody was like half of the group I
was talking to about taking the
responsibility where you go lead this
initiative this is your initiative that
you're leading and see if that makes
sense I said I'm not your boss I said
I'm telling I'm now your boss you're not
not you you're not my employee you're
all your own business owners you're
running your own franchises you own you
know independent contractors franchise
model but you're running your own deal
here
why relying on me in a communistic
philosophy everybody's relying on one
person to make because what I'm already
doing I'm saying you know what no
problem
you know best for me make the right
decisions for me you see what just
happened
yeah please make the right decisions for
me go who wants that responsibility
these are you you want to be God why
would anybody want to have all the right
response to this I'm terrible that's
terrible
yes some people that are still using
that regime and it's gonna be
interesting to see how long they like
what's what's always funny to me is when
some people want dead regime but they've
never lived down there before yeah when
some people think can you imagine what
if the right virtuous person showed up
and they did this yeah yeah that's a lot
of it sounds oh you're like coaching you
know you read a lot of books and people
have never coached you know power of
this and power positive thinking you got
to do this and you go watch bill a check
I mean it'll check wrote a book on
coaching you realize it's like some
people were like if he actually wrote
what he does to coach actual not you
know what you read about him uh written
by somebody that it's a very different
world to be a general to be a coach to
be a leader than it is to do anything
but I think pretty much everything looks
different from the outside they know
that about it this is why sometimes you
read the books you wonder like is it
really about him or not you know you you
hope to see the darker side of the
person because everybody's got it I want
to know that part of the person yeah I
don't wanna know like we learned about
you like austell magazine when you were
that's great you are officially human
okay yes the professor is psychiatrist
you know and a doctor who's talking
about that I want to know those things
because sometimes that makes the rest of
us think we can also be human so I got a
brother I cannot even tell you how much
fun I had with you I'm now gonna lie to
you I had no idea what to expect
sometimes I bring the educators and
professors and within 30 minutes I'm
knocked out sleep and you just don't
know I'm asleep but I had incredible
time with you I don't know
how long have you been talking about the
way hour and a half Wow just went by
most of them unit so to spend an hour
and half to get it this is a very
interesting topic what I want to tell
you guys is if you haven't yet read this
book we're gonna put the link below at
this point I'd say we didn't talk about
all the things that he talks about in
the book it's a very very important book
for you to read click on the link below
to go buy the book we're also gonna
leave a lot of the social media content
and Twitter handle his Twitter handle is
gonna be here as well if you took away
something from this video that really
inspired you send them a tweet send them
a message so you can hear from you as
well having said that said that dr.
Daniel Z Lieberman thank you so much
thanks so much for having really enjoyed
it man I really did it's been great so
you've probably never seen an interview
like this we went all over the place sex
love drugs porn all these different
things we talked about and if you like
this kind of interview I got two other
ones I want to recommend you one is a
interview I did with Jordan Peterson in
front of nearly 7,000 people where he
got emotional so if you want to watch
this one here very interesting because I
know we talked about Jordan Peterson in
the interview and if you've never seen
my sit-down with Dennis Prager very deep
very political we actually got into a
shouting match at one point you may
enjoy this one as well so if you want to
watch Dennis Prager click here if you
want to watch your own Peterson click
there and if you haven't yet subscribed
to the channel please do so take
everybody bye-bye
you
[Music]